I remember watching scary movie. That
was probably one of the first times I
was introduced to the idea of horror.
Yeah, it freaked me out. I had a TV in
my bedroom like at [music] the foot of
my bed that was very similar to TV in
the movie where this creepy girl crawled
out of and I was scared for life that
that girl's going to crawl out of my TV
when I'm trying to go to sleep.
>> But I have a friend. He was watching
something like that with a group of
friends. Stuff started flying across the
room.
>> Wait, while watching a movie. while
watching like a a horror like film.
>> What attracts people
>> to that kind of stuff? Do you ever watch
anything that give you nightmares?
>> Uh
I I say I hate horror movies. Uh but
actually sitting here talking with you
guys, uh I think I've actually seen
quite a few of them.
>> I think you've seen possibly more than
me.
>> What? Yeah. Yeah. See, that's the thing
though is that I I think you actually
watch more horror movies than you
realize. you do
>> because not everybody wants to sit down
and watch some like Scream movie, but
then I remember watching Scary Movie.
That was probably one of the first times
I was introduced to the idea of horror
and I was like, yeah, in my mind this
wasn't a horror movie cuz it's based on
a real horror movie, right? But it's
like raw humor or comedy or something
like that. But yeah, it freaked me out.
But I had a TV in my bedroom like at the
foot of my bed that was very similar to
TV in the movie where this creepy girl
crawled out of and I was scared for life
that that girl's going to crawl out of
my TV when I'm trying to go to sleep.
>> I I I always say to my wife, it's like I
don't have a lot of memories as a kid.
Um but I have one
um very distinct memory of being about 5
years old. Nightmare on Elm Street had
just come out. It had, you know, it was
in theaters.
>> Oh boy. And the TV was on at our house.
And I remember seeing the TV promotional
for that. And of course, what sticks out
in my mind are this hand from Freddy
Krueger going up through the bed and I
think it was supposed to be of this girl
or young person or something. It freaked
me out. I'm 5 years old, you know?
>> Yeah. And
it I I just remember so many times like
thinking about what's under my bed as a
kid after that. I mean it just it messes
with your head.
>> But you were five.
>> I was 5 years old,
>> dude.
>> You know, it's funny how movies can
shape um like a whole culture. Uh, you
know, people are scared of sharks
because of jaws.
>> And, you know, people probably didn't
think too much about the the water
before, but they I mean, they had a huge
swath of of people that would just kill
the sharks because
>> even if they're not like super super
dangerous. Um, so movies can affect
Yeah. a lot of things.
>> I think my mom told me that when she was
younger there, maybe you guys remember
this one uh there was this movie about
like birds, something like that where
just a bunch of birds came
>> like Albert Hitchcock.
>> Is that one?
>> I think so.
They were like they became like the
these predators and started eating
humans and all these kind of things and
like every generation has had their
shape or form of horror movies.
>> Yeah. Alfred Hitchcock. I mean, that's a
very famous famous, you know, shower
scene that everybody's probably seen.
The stabbing in the shower,
>> of course. Of course.
>> Used to watch with my of all people with
my parents. They were just into this
Tales from the Crypt,
>> which was actually based on a comic book
series.
>> And of course, yeah, HBO made it in on
TV. And then, you know, I remember as a
a teenager being into like Scream and I
know what you did last summer, but
probably mostly because, you know, I
thought there was a cute girl in it and
you that's what you're motivated as a a
young man.
>> You know, that's the thing that like
they're going to show you some
disgusting things where people are
getting murdered and then then they make
it this sort of seductive woman that I
think that's kind of rather disturbing,
right? That you would actually be um you
know, excited as a young boy about
somebody that's covered in blood. I
think that's very [snorts] disturbing.
>> When I was in my teens, I remember going
to uh I don't know was like Py Bay or
UTORN or something like that and you
know just like download this movie off
the internet and yeah, I didn't tell my
parents. I had a computer in my bedroom
so I was like whatever I'm just going to
do this. I illegally downloaded the
movie Saw because I went when back then
you still had the DVDs and all that kind
of stuff and there was a DVD a music
store in in town and I always saw those
DVD covers like on display for everyone
to see of Saw of the various movies that
they had and yeah it was like like
really gross looking like a dude with a
bunch of needles out of his head and
weird things like that. I was curious
and so I downloaded Saw and it was
literally of a dude having he was like
imprisoned or something or trapped and
he knew his family was outside and to
get to his family he was in chain so he
had to cut his legs off and drag himself
out of there to get to his family and he
had been dreamed into insanity and I
finished watching it and I thought never
again like that was so vile and it was
just you see how much of an impact it
has on you right because how many movies
do you remember the scenes of but this
kind of gory stuff is just in here
forever.
>> It's disturbing. It really is. I mean,
that's that's one of the reasons I I
could never watch stuff like Saws. It's
just
>> It was so disturbing to think about
cutting off your own leg or something to
get out of something.
>> But it's shocking as I sit back and
reflect how much of that junk I watched.
>> You know, a lot of it's crossover.
>> Alien, all the Alien films. I mean,
there's a lot of horrible stuff, scary
stuff that happens in there.
>> You have um like the Blair Witch
Project, you know, I remember watching
that. Why? I have no idea. It's like
>> I you know, I look back and I wondered
what attracts people
>> to that kind of stuff.
>> Yeah.
>> I think like anything like you want to
watch movies because of the way that
they make you feel.
>> But I don't like being scared.
>> Yeah. I don't know. I it is a it is a
strange thing that people want to feel
these different emotions. But I think
there's a danger of like revving up your
fight orflight system and then not not
it doesn't do anything like you
suppressed it. You're not getting up and
running out of the theater. You're just
sitting there watching these terrible
things happen and eating popcorn and
eating candy.
>> Do you know it's the most horror is the
most divisive movie genre? It's split
almost down the middle like 25% in each
section like love it, hate it, you know,
kind of love it, kind of hate it across
the board. It's it's almost even in each
of those categories. It's really weird.
>> So, and um when people when you look at
like movie making, typically horror
films are more lowbudget.
>> Mhm.
>> But they have the greatest returns.
>> Mhm. So there's also incentive for
Hollywood to keep making them because
they have very loyal audiences and they
have great returns on them. It's like
400% generally.
>> I think there's a very weird real world
things that happen when they're making
horror films. Um you know I I have heard
that there is kind of this common
denominator where something really
tragic actually happens. Like some of
the more evil horror movies uh the
actors will die, something will happen
on the set. weird things when they made
the omen like the plane with the writer
and the director as they're coming over.
One of the actors struck by lightning
and three or four Yeah. three or four of
the other cast members and people that
were all flying to the location got
struck by lightning in the plane and you
know the plane can take some lightning
but but that's just weird in general. I
mean I fly a lot. You fly a lot. Have
you ever been struck by lightning? No.
>> But didn't you say it was like three
different occasions that plane was
struck or something like that?
>> Yeah. And and even in one of um I think
um one of the scenes the writer had
written it in such a way that uh there
was a helicopter crash and the
helicopter killed the two boys that were
that were in there and the actor. But
what was really weird about it was uh
this the writer wrote that exact scene
and it happened exactly like that scene
and he had written that prior to that
thing happening. So
>> yeah,
>> that's like Grant Morrison stuff. I was
about to say,
>> yeah, you know,
>> tell me tell more about that.
>> Well, he was he was writing in the comic
books and the stuff that he was writing
was actually happening to him.
>> Yep. In Grant's book, Super Gods, he
says,
>> "I came out in boils, a traditional sign
of demon [music] contact. I hallucinated
something I recognized immediately as
Christ. I understood [music] that this
power I was facing was some kind of
gnostic Christ, a Christ of the
Apocrypha, [music] an almost pagan
figure that I'd found at the bottom at
the last gasp.
You know, I'd become the character. I
was wearing the clothes. I was going to
the places. [music] I was doing the
things. I was doing the rituals. I was
hanging out with the gods and then
putting it back in the comic and then
being affected [music] by what was in
the comic. So, yeah. I mean, in terms of
reality, that one was the actual deal.
You know, that one was bringing me to
the [music] the verge of death.
>> When Grant was working on The Invisib,
he got sick. Right around the time that
character [music] got sick.
>> Just after King Mo had been convinced by
the bad guys that he had been given a
necroizing fasciitis bacteria that was
eaten through his face, I suddenly
[music] get this huge boil on my face.
And within 3 days, it's enormous.
Distorted my entire feature. I was I was
sweating constantly. I was going to
fevers and having these like shakes and
riggers and then freezing. I just
couldn't get up anymore and I lay in
front of the the fireplace in my house.
>> I mean, he thought he was going to die.
I mean, he he broken he broken down in
tears and he was like he was delirious,
man. Delilarious.
>> And suddenly this giant column of
[music] light comes through the door.
And bear in mind, I'm hallucinating, but
this was one of the most amazing
hallucinations I've ever had. And
[music] it's Jesus. The first thing he
said, which is the thing I put in the
column, just this voice suddenly
announced itself. I am not the [music]
God of your fathers. I am the hidden
stone that breaks all hearts. So then he
said to me, "Okay, you're about to die
now, but you don't have to die." And I
said, "Look, I really don't want to die.
[music] What do I have to do?" And he
said, "Well, if you want to stay here,
you have to work for us. You know, you
have to spread the
>> Yeah. Well, also Andrew Bikinsky, we
just had him on our show. We have the
episode on our channel. He was a I would
say he was pretty high up in Hollywood
as a camera operator. Worked with Jude
Law and Oh, what's the girl who was in
the first Spider-Man movie? Kristen
Dunce or
>> Kristen Dun. Yes. Yes. Um and he did
like four days or something like that on
the set of uh Steven Spielberg. Did some
some X cam for him. Uh that was actually
where Drew Law was as as well. But he
said that he had a friend who had was
working on a Hollywood horror movie and
that friend told him they actually had
to bring in a priest
>> to exorcise like cast out demons off the
set because there were so many strange
things happening to people. People were
getting hurt on the set and they
realized something really dark was
actually going on.
>> Gregory Peek's son was going to be on a
horror movie and the very first day he
ended up taking his own life.
>> Yeah.
>> You've got the crow where there was that
crazy scene that Brandon Lee got shot
with a real gun and nobody knows which
one it was and you know it's wild.
>> I remember watching the show on MTV cuz
I I grew up with Nickelodeon and MTV. I
did not grow up a Christian. Um, and uh,
yeah, there was this show about these
girls that wanted to become Hollywood
actresses. So, they put them through all
kinds of demonic things. And I remember
specifically one of the things they made
them do, and these were just like
standard girls from the street, right,
who just wanted to be famous. One of the
things they made them do was to go
outside and I think they had some kind
of a ritual outside like with witches
and I'm pretty sure there might have
been a pentagram in Fall Evolved, like
weird things like that. And so again,
why if all you want to do is just be an
actress in a horror movie and just act
like you're scared, why do you have to
go through all of those rituals in order
to get there?
>> Yeah.
>> Didn't you say there's some like like
huge percentage return on those movies?
>> Yeah. Like 400%.
>> 400%. So that's based on like another
film. Like films are usually, you know,
double or whatever.
>> Yeah. Like more than action, more than
drama. I mean, action was second most,
but more than drama, more than comedy,
more than any other genre.
>> So, they're cheap to make and it's got a
really good return. And so, the
incentive to me would be if that horror
movie can do much better, you make more
money. So, it doesn't shock me that they
would be doing ritualistic things to try
to push their thing out there.
>> So, I know of this never happened to me
that I can remember or know of like
watching anything like that, but I have
a friend, it's funny because his
birthday is actually today. Um he was
watching something like that with a
group of friends and he said it was the
weirdest thing like stuff started flying
across the room.
>> Wait, while watching a movie?
>> While watching like a like a a horror
like film.
>> Yeah.
>> See, I never I never saw anything weird
like that. And and when I was younger,
you know, my brother and I we we kind of
went through this phase where we we
didn't watch that stuff as kids. So, I
think we kind of over consumed when we
when we had the opportunity to make
those choices ourselves. And so, we we
would watch tons of those things. And
yeah, I was scared, but I also think it
really just numbed me
>> to feeling empathetic towards people or
things or whatever like that. I mean, I
mean, how can that not have some sort of
impact upon your psychology or your, you
know, care for other people if you can
sit there and eat popcorn and candy and
watch people die and you're getting
enjoyment out of that? It is kind of a
weird phenomenon.
>> It is. Yeah.
>> Yeah. Um I I I can't remember
specifically like connecting. I watched
this movie and then this happened. But
again, I didn't grow up a Christian. So
in our house, we had music that was
super satanic, like Hell's Bells,
Highway to Hell. My dad was always
playing that music. I was listening to
classical rock like AC/DC and all that
kind of stuff. Um and then we read Harry
Potter. We had we my mom's from South
Africa so we brought brought back like
African masks and things like that. So I
think we had a lot of things around our
house including sometimes you know
watching those horror movies or other
movies that were full of violence and
gory things like that that stuff was
happening in our house but I don't think
horror movies were the only avenue. I
think they were one of the avenues. Um I
I remember specifically I was about 12
13 years old
>> that I I felt I felt myself levitating
on my bed
>> and I would open my eyes and I was still
saw myself moving like I was like
sideways and I was mo I was moving like
this and so I screamed and as my dad
came in he was like oh you're just
dreaming. I'm like I was not dreaming. I
had my eyes wide open. I I felt my whole
body moving. There were things like
that. Um, and it was only really after I
became a Christian, got baptized and and
people had come and actually prayed over
a home and I started getting rid of the
stuff that I had and started changing
what I was watching that these things
disappeared.
>> Yeah. You know, when you you touch on
the Harry Potter stuff, which isn't like
horror, but it's it's witchcraft.
>> It's dark. It's dark.
>> Yeah. There are places and words in
those films that are they're used in the
real world.
>> I mean, they're real world places and
they're real magic words that are used.
It's not all just like play, not all
made up.
>> Yeah. I think some of the names of the
characters are actually real demon
names.
>> Yeah. I mean, she was writ JK Rowling or
Rowling, however you say her name, she
was riding a train
>> when she saw Harry Potter. Like, what
did you see? You were wide awake. What
happened? You know, it's Yeah. Yeah. And
we actually at the at the time of when
we released this video, we actually have
a a video on our channel of a girl who
um start seeing demons that had knives
that wanted to attack her because she
was involved with Harry Potter and all
these things. So, definitely interesting
to check that out. link in description.
>> So, there's definitely crossover
sometimes when you're watching stuff and
>> supernatural events.
>> There's also physical responses. I don't
know if you guys can when I started
investigating on this, I'm like, why why
do people keep going back? Because it
seems like a lot of this stuff is the
worst of humanity,
>> you know, like why would you want to see
some human be being do that to another
human being? Um, but there's physical
responses. So like your uh your body
will read these surges of epinephrine
and what that can do is cause your uh
your blood vessels, your arteries um to
be damaged.
>> Um and this is repeated like repeated
exposure. It's not like it happens once
it's going to happen that way. I think
God designs our system so that we
respond to something naturally, but then
if we keep artificially doing it, that's
when we get in trouble, you know, like
or we put ourselves at risk. So
obviously we have this inborn or pseudo
natural. I call it pseudonatural because
I don't think we were ever truly made to
be scared, but we have the response,
right? So if we see something, we get
scared, we respond to it. That that
appears to be natural. It's not going to
be that way in heaven because there's
nothing scary, but that's the way it is
here on this earth. But if you um
if you have epinephrine being released
in your system quite a bit, it can be
also raising your blood pressure and
giving you um increased risk of heart
attack and stroke. And a compound factor
in all that is when you're watching
these kinds of things, um, it elevates
your cortisol levels.
>> When you elevate your cortisol levels,
>> then, um, it kind of inadvertently helps
build up, um, fat tissue. And so then of
course we know if you're
more predisposed to um obesity or a
sedentary lifestyle or all of that then
it you start this vicious circle you
know what I mean because now you're
building up these fat stores in your
body and then that also makes you know
generally the things that go with that
increased risk of heart attack and
stroke and things like that. So it just
keeps kind of going. So if you keep
going and watching those kind of things
are freaking you out, it kind of feeds
itself and that's not the best for your
health.
>> I also just looked looked this up that
and and I assumed that this would happen
that you get an adrenaline hit because
your body is trying to protect itself.
Have you ever felt adrenaline go through
your body?
>> Oh yeah.
>> Yeah. You feel like this flush, right?
>> You can feel like when you're in a
situation that you feel is either
dangerous or I should not be here or
whatever and you you feel your system
kind of wake up. It's like get ready to
run if we have to.
>> Yeah. I feel like this I don't know how
you can say it, but like almost Yeah.
Like like you can if you had to
visualize it, it like there's this thing
that just comes over you like it flushes
over you because it just shoots through
your whole body.
>> And that's addictive, too.
>> Yeah.
>> And dopamine is the other thing that
comes in.
>> Mhm. And it seems kind of
counterintuitive, but people that
actually watch a lot of horror and
stuff, they get a hit of dopamine from
watching all that stuff cuz they come
off of all the scary, all the fight or
flight or whatever. And there's this
satisfactory response at the end like,
I'm still alive. I made it through. It's
all okay.
>> So, you get this feelgood release at the
end of it. And that of course repeated
exposure buildup just like being on your
phone, you know, social media, other
types of film genre and you get addicted
to it.
>> No, Dr. New Netley, he talks about
addictions in his uh depression, anxiety
recovery program. I'm a volunteer in the
program at our at our church. And so he
talks about the effects of a dopamine
when you have addictions, right? So he
shows you this graph and maybe I can
even find his graph exactly or or you
know look look for for something similar
to show you but he shows this graph and
basically this is like your steady line
of dopamine
>> homeostasis.
>> Yes. Homeostasis.
>> And so he says what happens is let's
sort of say for example you watch a
horror movie and you get this dopamine
hit, right? It goes up but then it goes
lower to where it was before. So now
that's your bottom like base basically.
And then you do it again and it goes
lower and lower and lower and it
actually can cause depression and
anxiety because your dopamine base is so
much lower and you feel like you have to
keep going back to it to get your
dopamine up. And so what happens in the
beginning especially is now your
dopamine hit your high is actually your
previous base.
>> Yeah.
>> So and that's extremely unhealthy.
>> So you never actually get the same
happiness or joy or satisfaction. But if
you do healthy things like let's say for
example you get a dopamine hit because I
don't know you um
>> you got a hug from somebody.
>> You get a hug from somebody you actually
it stays up much longer and it's more
consistent. It doesn't drop as easily.
>> Well like yeah like anything you're
going to get addicted to that drug and
they're going to keep coming back to the
watering hole. So I'm sure they at least
know that and they're going to push the
envelope which that's why I think things
are getting sicker and more weird. And I
mean, if you watch a horror movie from
probably when we were kids, it's scary,
but not like today's movies. Today's
movies are just downright like
>> absolutely scary.
>> And there's ways of measuring that. You
know, you you're probably I know you're
familiar with the term neurosinema. Mhm.
>> So, the scariest movies by today's
standards, I don't even recognize cuz I
didn't see them, but you look at the
statistics and they're like showing you
what people's elevated heart rates are
and all this kind of stuff.
That's kind of fascinating.
um tracking eye movement,
heart rate, you know, different physical
markers to
measure I mean even fMRI brain scans to
measure how somebody is responding to a
piece of media.
>> So, have you found out anything
interesting?
>> Well, when when we kind of stumbled on
that, we were looking at investigating
like um the just the the different ways
that they will do market research. How
do they make this movie more exciting or
more because because that's really what
they're after, right? If if they can
give you a better emotional rush, you'll
come back to the movie. We saw that with
like Titanic, right? People came back
like 10 times that movie.
>> Wow. Yeah. So, um there were some groups
out of Stanford in California and or you
know around Davis and and that would do
what they call neurosinema what you're
describing here and they're basically
sending people in an fMRI machine and
then showing um clips of the movies and
then checking are their brains reacting
to this in the way that we want and if
it wasn't they would go back and they
would recut it so that you would get
this maximum amount of emotional rush to
it. So, it's like they're scientifically
now figuring out how to give you that
little dopamine hit. And what's scary is
now compound that in today's world where
it's like I'm sure if you throw AI into
that situation where it's like now tell
me the formula of how to make this the
most scariest addictive movie, I'm sure
AI is going to come up with some very
disgusting things to drive this thing
even further down the road. And so, I
think yeah, it's time to get a handle on
this now. So, I just looked up this too
uh about what happens to your brain
since we're talking about it. So, your
amygdala, the brain's alarm system,
instantly signals your hypothalamus,
which flips on the body's fightor-flight
response. I know
>> I think you and I weren't even working
here yet. We didn't work in this
documentary that he worked on, right?
Okay. So, [clears throat] you worked on
a documentary called Sudology, which
means the art of lying, which is all
about media and how it affects the
brain. This is like way back in the
heyday of when little studios came
about. But what did you learn from
science about the fight orflight system?
>> Well, you know, it's a weird thing to to
scare you and get you ready to prepare
to run or be active like that. That's
like revving up the system. But then by
suppressing it constantly, meaning
you're not running out of the theater,
you're you're not actually in any real
danger. Yeah, it it's it's like pulling
the lever of, you know, making that rush
come about you and then each time that
rush is going to significantly get less
and less and less. Now, what if you have
to actually run? What if you actually
have to do something? I mean, you know,
you've kind of taxed that system. And
so, you know, they're after that. They
want that because that's going to drive
people to come and and watch these
things. And I think everybody that goes
to watch horror movies, why would you
want to sit in a room and watch somebody
be um dismembered?
>> Yeah. I mean, it's a weird It's a weird
thing just to think about in general.
Like, why are we attracted to that? Like
Halloween, for example.
>> Like, I just went camping this weekend
and it's like when we drove into the
camp ground, there were there were um
things hanging from the trees from nooes
and it was like why would they want to
do that as a form of decoration or
something where it's like what if you
had a family member that committed
suicide? Would you not be offended
driving into that campground and seeing
somebody hung at the tree, you know, and
it's like weird that we are fascinated
by death.
>> Yeah. All the neuro cinema stuff also
spills over into what's called
neuromarketing.
Um I don't know if you've ever seen
this, but um Campbell Soup many years
ago started changing their labels. Mhm.
>> And the way they were measuring that is
an audience's emotional response to
different elements on the soup labels.
So for example, they added steam
>> because if there was steam that
indicated warmth and people were more
emotionally drawn to the warmth. They
were they would like remove the spoon
because people had no emotional
attachment to it. So all these different
elements and the one thing that was
always in common was people's emotional
responses to the different things that
are there graphically. And so it's
fascinating the level of detail and the
amount of money that's spent to study
how we respond to different things. And
and basically at the end of the day it's
essentially biochemical manipulation.
>> And that that's all has to do with your
subconscious, right? You don't just go
into the store and look at them like,
man, I'm really emotionally responsive
now to the steam. You don't you don't
you just look at the package and you're
like, I really want some soup right now.
You don't even know why you thought
that. Like, you weren't planning to buy
it. Nothing. It's just something
happened in your brain. And I think it's
the same goes with the horror movies,
right? It's all working on our
subconscious and you don't have much to
say about it unless you just avoid it.
>> Well, bring that into the Christian
realm. Now, you have um something that
you're dealing with that's very
supernatural. I mean, the Bible talks
about demonic spirits and those kind of
things, right? But you're watching these
movies that do not enter into the
conversation at all, how to overcome
that or how to battle that or God's not
even a part of that picture. So, they're
resolving these demonic things outside
of the realm of of, you know, God having
power over that demon. And so I think
even in a subtle way that's that's
bending our belief that like hey if I
saw a demon God needs to help me, you
know, protect me against that thing. And
here we've watched all these movies that
like you resolve it yourself. You have a
bigger gun. You have a cross made out of
wood or whatever like this. You stab
them. I mean it's just like outside of
God.
>> Yeah. There's a lot of supernatural
stuff that happens in horror films.
>> Mhm.
>> And I don't just mean like it physically
happens. It's depicted, right? Like they
want to show that on screen
>> and all that stuff. God told Israel a
long time ago like don't go there
>> like ever. Just don't touch it with a
10-ft pole. And so the fact that we go
and watch it
>> and enjoy it is actually really strange.
>> Um we did an episode with David. He's
from Malaysia and I would say he's an
expert in demonic manifestations and and
you know like how to overcome demonic
possession and all that kind of stuff
like casting it out he's cast it out of
many people and he actually talked about
that horror movies many movies but
specifically horror movies are an open
door to the de demonic realm and to ask
them to come into your life you have to
give him permission and that's what
you're doing
>> you know I don't think we're going to
get to heaven and say, "Man, I wish I
watched one more horror film."
>> Mhm.
>> Or, "I'm I'm so glad I watched that
before I got here, or I'm so upset that
I missed the sequel to this other one."
I don't think that will enter into our
our thinking at all because heaven is a
place of light
>> and happiness and love and peace. Horror
films don't give you any of that. Mhm.
>> So
there's nothing there for us but
emptiness.
And when you think about it, most of the
time they're just depicting the worst
the absolute worst parts of our human
nature.
>> Mhm.
>> Absolute worst parts of humanity. So for
me,
what I I like what the Bible says.
There's a scripture in Psalm 119. It
says, "Turn away my eyes from looking at
worthless things and revive revive me in
your way."
>> Psalm 119 verse 37. Those are worthless
things. And the Bible's like, "Just just
don't even look at worthless things.
They're they're not worth your time.
They're not going to do anything for
you."
>> There's a lot of physical evidence that
what we watch impacts us. That's why we
worked on that documentary called
Pseudology was really to just to prove
we know this thing affects you. We know
that you watch something and your body
responds to it and they can cause you to
have an action over here.
>> And so like that's I think why Paul
penned in in Philippians, right?
whatever is pure, whatever is lovely,
whatever is of good report. Focus on
these things because if you do that, you
you you set the mind on on on heavenly
things and you think about what an
amazing thing that's going to be to go
to heaven. And I don't think we talk
about heaven enough.
>> Yeah.
>> And I think some of these these things
that just keep this darkness around us.
It's like it makes you familiar with
darkness.
>> And the more familiar you are with those
things, the more your mind will fall
into those ruts. So do a Daniel
challenge.
>> Don't watch anything like that for
>> a extended period of time and see how
your body reacts to that.
>> Go through the holiday season. Don't
watch one horror movie. Just watch
something lovely and pure and see what
that does to you.
>> Study your Bible.
>> Yeah. I like what you said there, Keith,
about in heaven. [clears throat] It's
it's light, right? 1 John 15 says this
is the message which we have heard from
him meaning Jesus and declared to you
that God is light and in him is no
darkness at all and you know it just
reminds me of I believe we are very
close to the second coming of Jesus and
we have to ask ourselves the question is
like the way we are living our life are
we preparing for that are we prepare are
our hearts really desiring to be in
heaven and are our actions showing that
because out of the heart the mouth
speaks right and you can fruits you
shall know them So if your life is
revolved around well I want to watch all
this darkness and stuff then and heaven
is light and in Jesus there is no
darkness then you really have to ask
yourself like where are you headed and I
remember there's this story
of
it's this idea that there's train and
Satan is the train conductor and the
train is full of people who are just
distracted who are involved in
worldliness who don't even realize
realize who the conductor is, but he is
riding them straight toward destruction.
And yeah, I I think God wants us to wake
up because that's the fast track to
death. And he wants to give us life. And
he h wants to give us hope and light.
And we have a option. We can choose to
get off the train and walk the narrow
walk that Jesus wants us to. And I hope
that when people hear that that they
will make that decision for Jesus, you
know, like fill yourself with his light
and his glory. Yeah. Right.
>> Oftentimes those things that's what
they're depicting more than anything
else is death.
>> Mhm.
>> When God came, Jesus says, "I came that
they might have life and have it more
abundantly." So,
>> we need to get our priorities straight.
And I look back at my own life and I'm
like that none of that did I've watched
way more than I realized that I did.
>> And it didn't do me any good.
>> Mm-m. didn't add anything to my life. In
fact, it detracted
from it. And you know, I have all those
memories and I can't get rid of them.
>> That's right.
[music]